each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'm very happy to introduce Cormac
Flanagan who's a professor at associate
professor now at UC Santa Cruz so he'll
be here all of this week and he's
interested in talking to two people to
find out common topics of interest
looking for long-term collaboration so I
just wanted to say a few words about
what Cormac has worked on in the past
I'll do a little reverse do a reverse
chronological order so most recently has
been working on fine checking concurrent
programs various kinds of properties
like absence of races and Adam City
violations and things like that he also
worked on a static checking in the
context of the two esc Java that some of
you might have heard of and automated
theorem proving and for that he also has
worked on type systems for functional
programming languages in the context of
his PhD thesis and in other work today
is going to talk about some of the work
he did on checking and current programs
okay lectures yeah so this is joint work
that I guess I did together with Steve
friend and she has that kind of start up
when we're all back at this systems
research center many years ago and that
Steve and I have continued working on
over the years and the motivation for
this is if i can get this right pretty
much multithreading has been around it's
always been problematic with the advent
of all these multi-core processors
there's probably a lot of people here
worried about the same kind of problem
right modi's writer software is very
difficult to get right we need to write
more multi-threaded software to exploit
these multi-core processors and well we
need multiple core processors because
sequential single core processors just
aren't getting faster anymore so we need
to do something with all those
transistors multi-core processors
multi-threaded software
and all the issues that come with
multi-threaded software right there's
this combinatorial explosion of
interleaving zat testing is so much
harder because it's very hard to get
good coverage so we have this whole
motivation behind our study of
multi-threaded code now at the same time
writing software is always hard pipe
systems kind of traditional type systems
have proven really helpful at catching
certain kinds of errors you right in the
type language you never get errors at
one time that you called a method with
the wrong number of arguments all those
things are called at compile time so for
certain kinds of errors pipe systems
have proven really well so what we've
been trying to do is try to put these
two worlds together right we want type
systems not just for a sequential
software but for all these kinds of
errors that kind of crop up and are so
insidious in multi-threaded software
namely race conditions and atom City
violations wrong one
so I'm going to try and illustrate these
ideas pretty concretely I know this is
the right after lunch slot and I was
sitting in the audience here yesterday
after I had a good lunch and it was it
was hard to stay awake so I'll try to
keep this interactive as much as
possible some of you may have seen some
of this stuff before so feel free to
speed me up if you've seen it feel free
to ask lots of questions and in return
I'm going to ask you some questions
along the way so it will keep things
interactive so as a running example for
this talk here is just a simple class
this is Java code pretty much the same
as C sharp code more or less a class
that implements a reference cell so
we've got to feel that contains the
counter and a method to add to reference
cells we create to reference cells x is
0 Y has three we add Y to X twice and is
X guaranteed to contain six
this is the whole program icic that's
ahead snarling yeah so so this is fine
usual stuff we all know if we added
multi-threading things get more
complicated right and it's a little bit
harder to reason about all the possible
data leavings but it's probably a number
of you in the audience are getting
pretty suspicious about this assertion
right yeah I see heads nodding right in
the usual thing that's going on here is
we have race conditions right which I'll
define for this talk fairly standard
definition of two threads that access a
shared variable at the same time and at
least one of these accesses is a right
so the two ads are both reading and
writing to I at the same time they kind
of met each other up maybe only one of
them will happen depending on the
interleaving and there's lots of
interleaving and so this assertion might
fail so old stuff how do we deal with it
well if we're good programmers we put in
synchronization into your code into our
code so you might have something like
this each thread will first acquire the
locks on x and y and then do this method
call so here's a trickier question do
you have confidence in this assertion
now
yes
so we have one yes I think we have a few
yeses so yes this this coat seems fine
and if we scratch our heads and stereo
for a while we can gain confidence than
that but what we'd really like or what I
much of my research is on is to say well
listen how would we develop type systems
to be able to reason about the race
freedom in this kind of code right to
kind of automate this tedious reasoning
that we're all kind of scratching our
heads and trying to do right now and for
this kind of fairly straightforward lock
based synchronization discipline it
works out reasonably well so as usual we
have code it's in a type language we've
type annotations we've int and ref and
other things in various places to have a
type system for preventing race
conditions we throw in some more type
annotations so on fuel declarations we
say this is a field at its holds
integers and it's guarded by this lock
right the implicit lock of this object
and on method declarations we say every
time you call this method you got to
provide a ref cell and you gotta hold
these two locks okay so that's kind of
what the program it does the the
annotation side of things and then the
the type system are you can think of it
as the compiler there's a bunch of
checks at a compile-time basically
making sure that these these annotations
are followed the synchronization
discipline that the annotations describe
are followed so we have access to a
field I this check is pretty
straightforward we just I is protected
by this from the requires clause i know
we have these two locks so this check
passes okay that's really easy stuff the
second check gets a little bit more
interesting so I is guarded by this
right but when we're accessing this this
field that this we're talking about is
our so we actually have to substitute do
the substitution over here to take care
of the fact that the object we're really
talking about is are so audit I is
indeed protected by our that's one of
the locks that's held at this point in
the program we know that from the
requires clause and so fairly easy kind
of compile time check
those two things hold so provided this
kind of requirement is satisfied at all
call sites we know that this method add
is race free down below we have some
similar kinds of checks so what do we do
here we are going to call add we need to
have the locks this and are right but
this and are expressed in terms of kind
of the formal parameters have add so
down here we need to replace them by the
corresponding actual parameters right
the this that we're actually talking
about is X and the are that we're
passing in is actually going to be this
argument why so we do the substitution
on the locks that must be held we check
that these locks are held at this point
on the program which clearly comes from
the synchronized clause so this check
passes another call side same kind of
check and for kind of an idealized
nicely behaved subset of Java we can
have a sound a theorem that says if your
program passes the type checker then
it's guaranteed to be raised free
practice things aren't quite so nice you
need some ways to escape from the type
system when it proves too restrictive
much like you have cast cincy but but
for the underlying theory it's nice to
have this this kind of sinus theorem
okay okay the type system requires that
for each one in each other
for each field local variables don't get
sure between threads so it's not an
issue the second part of the talk then
tackles type inference which is how do
we infer these things automatically
exactly for that kind of concern oh no
that the x and y's that are mentions to
synchronize statements are really the
same same objects what x and y are
different objects no no you have to
synchronized oh if you update it x yeah
if you said X gets why then all better
off absolutely and I kind of discuss the
main things but not some of the details
and one is that all of these lock
expressions must be const they cannot
refer to mutable data at all that's
absolutely true okay so this is this
type system is very nice it's a little
bit basic and breaks down in some places
to give you a feel for that here's a bit
of a trickier example where I isn't
protected by the dislike any more so
this is a bit trickier we have some
extra lock em and each of the two
different threads is going to acquire em
before doing this X dot of Y so trick
your examples same kind of question are
we confident about this assert
okay I agree and then we want to feed
this into the type system so we'll have
to say int i guarded by hot this is
where it gets tricky we'd like to say
something like guarded by am but M isn't
in scope up there and even if you could
play some ugly trips tricks to make it
in scope you might have different
clients of ref that have refs guarded by
some other lock so we kind of need to
extend the type system to say not just
talk about you know objects of class
rift but we need to say refs protected
by lock em are rest protected by some
other lock so we had a notion of
parameterization to the type system kind
of like the type parameters in Java five
but these are classes not parameterised
by other types but parameterised by
locks so when we declare class ref we
say okay it's going to be parameterized
by some ghost lock G ok so G is a
variable it doesn't exist at runtime
just at compile time and that's why it's
called a ghost variable and we say well
whatever G is we're going to use it to
protect the field I when you call the
method add you better hold that lock and
you better pass it a reference cell
that's also parameterised by the same
lock right so we're giving a more kind
of flexible specification for this class
and then down here we can simply say ah
we have x and y they're both reference
cells protected by M and then the
compiler is able to do the same kind of
type checking reasoning as before to
give you a flavor of that what we do
here is ok we're going to call the
method add we better make sure that this
lock G is held and again we'll take
whatever that requires clauses will
replace the formal parameters this and
our x x and y but the object that we're
dispatching on x is a parameterised by M
so we're going to replace the the ghost
parameter G by the actual parameter of
the object X which is M
okay so we do this whole substitution
will say ah the lock we really need to
have when we call this X out of Y is M
and indeed we have it it comes from the
synchronized clause ok so these lock
parameters are ghosts parameters they
add some complexity to the type system
but they gave it a lot of flexibility to
you can include things like threadlocal
data in this way by saying it's ref is
parameterised by some a threadlocal lock
so essentially once we had this type
system it was a pretty good at handling
most of the kind of code we needed to
deal with yeah if in your experience
does it seem like the race conditions
that exist in real programs come about
from people making mistakes about which
locks are held for because aliasing
because they end up with aliasing that's
uncontrollable because I'm wondering
like this system depends upon freedom
from aliasing not really
I mean it sound even in the presence of
aliasing you said the looks were calm
yes yes it's beautiful sort of memory
things at least if you write data
structures
so a few things there so mutation of
lock expressions is different from
aliasing right are there different kinds
of causes of concern mostly the error
comes from people just forget to acquire
any lock and there is this issue going
on that we require that this lock
expression is syntactically the same as
this lock expression and you could
imagine well you'll call it m here but
we'll put it into some variable foo over
here and synchronize on foo instead of
em and then the type system would kind
of not be able to reason about that
aliasing and that's certainly a weakness
and surprisingly we never found that in
practice I mean we kind of deal with
this aliasing between formal and actual
parameters by substitution and that
really seems to be almost all of what we
need and this other issue of mutable
lock expressions comes up from time to
time and it's kind of the corner cases
we cannot deal with that certainly one
of them yeah you have a question
Oh
the races
program which raises on purpose yes
takes it
so that's kind of some of these skates
from the type system we talked about on
a field declaration you can put in this
annotation saying no Warren if you find
races don't tell me about it I don't
care I know they're there they're benign
for some other reason so those do come
up from time to time to sew in our
experience by and large this
parameterize type system was enough to
reason about you know race freedom
unlike ninety percent of the fields in a
program the downside was just the
overhead of having to go through and
figuring out all of these annotations
and so that may have motivated our work
on type inference is there some
automatic way to figure out all of these
annotations and it turns out when we
first looked at this if you don't have
these kind of ghost parameters it's
fairly easy it's like an N cubed
algorithm pretty straightforward but of
course goes parameters they are just see
going forward they are just necessary so
the problem we want to solve is given
some mostly unannotated program maybe
with some annotations in there can we do
type inference to figure out all of
these annotations particularly in the
presence of ghosts and what we found out
is this is surprisingly hard be nice if
there was some monotonically converging
algorithm we could have but everything
we looked at required making some choice
exploring something if that didn't work
out backtracking and trying some other
choice and so some kind of exponential
time search to give you a flavor of why
that is suppose somewhere in our type
inference we find out that this check is
violated right does that mean we need to
change the sanitation up here are is
this ref of em was that wrong should it
be ref of something else so that's kind
of gives you the idea of where we could
get into this this backtracking search
so we tried you know various kinds of
approaches none of them worked out
particularly well and eventually we you
know every algorithm we came up with was
exponential time we were feeling pretty
dumb and then we thought well hang on a
sec there's another common search
problem that
is it's only solvable by backtracking
search propositional satisfiability you
know maybe type inference is np-complete
and indeed kind of discouraging that
turns out to be the case if you take
some sub problem you can create a
program such that if you can do type
inference for it then that corresponds
to solving the sap problem so first this
is a kind of negative result right it
says type inference boy it's just really
hard but there's a another way to look
at it which is that NP complete is not
as hard a problem as it used to be it's
pretty funny but over the past five
years people who made phenomenal
progress on these fast SAT solvers right
I don't know how many orders of
magnitude they've gotten faster but it's
it's really substantial so let's just
leverage all of that hard engineering
work that you know other people have
done with heuristics and representations
and all this stuff and so the
architecture we hit on was well we'll
just take our program and find some way
to construct a SAP problem for it so
that when we crank it through a chaff or
whatever your favorite SAT solver is and
it if it solves it we can just kind of
translate the solution back into type
annotations for the program right we're
solving an np-complete problem let's
just use really good tools to do that
and put all of our stuff elsewhere and
you know once we hit on this
architecture everything else is kind of
fell into place pretty easily so the way
this works is we do have some heuristic
bound on the number of ghost variables
for each class typically two or three
works really well because programs
mostly don't need more than that for
this example to keep it simple let's use
just one okay so the first thing we do
is we put in these annotations with a
bunch of unknowns alpha and beta alpha 1
alpha 2 beta
and the whole goal of type inference is
to figure out what alphas and betas
should be and we're going to use a
constraint based approach so we'll just
translate this whole program into a
bunch of constraints over alpha and beta
ok so for alpha 1 is got to be some
valid lock in scope there's only two
such locks at this point in the program
this and G so alpha 1 has got to be one
of those two alpha 2 is the same and
beta is some set of locks that can only
contain this G&R so beta is some subset
of those ones ok and then for the body
of the code well alpha one must be in
beta so that we hold a write lock right
here and here a little bit more
complicated if we take alpha 1 which is
a protecting lock for I but we need to
say ah but this we're talking about is
our and the object that we're looking at
is going to be protected by our
parameterised by alpha 2 so we have
these delayed substitutions in our
constraints right earlier we knew what
this thing was and we could just do the
substitutions right away but now we
don't know what alpha 1 is so the
substitution is kind of sits around for
a little bit ok so we just need a
solution to this constraint system now
the key thing here is if you look at the
first three constraints I will call them
kind of scope constraints they really
bound the whole solution space right
they just say you know alpha 1 is one of
two choices alpha 2 is one or two
choices and this is I guess one of eight
choices for beta so it's a very finite
solution space and we can encode that
solution space using a bunch of boolean
variables
so boolean variable be one is going to
decide what is alpha one is it this orgy
ever eat more choices we may need kind
of a bigger decision tree with the same
idea we'll use b2 to encode alpha 2 and
then be three four and five to save
which is these three elements are in
this set it be three decides if this is
in there before five decide for gnr okay
so if you give me a boolean variables
I'll tell you what the alphas and betas
are ok so now all that remains is to use
this encoding to translate these
remaining constraints in to sac clauses
and let's look at the second constraint
cuz it's kind of the interesting one and
so this is really just a bunch of kind
of at this stage basic algebra just kind
of work through it in a few steps just
to keep everything concrete so we have
this constraint we need to solve and we
know what alpha 1 is we have this
encoding over here so we'll just stick
that in and now this delayed
substitution that was kind of waiting
around for a while now we can finally
apply it right because we know what this
thing is so we do that substitution and
so we get this constraint b1 ? our colon
alpha 2 must be in beta we know what
these two things are so we'll just
substitute them in and we'll get this
this big constraint not quite a
sub-problem yet but suppose be one was
true then this left hand side must be R
so R must be in this set over here so we
know that b5 is true ah so that's a
sackcloth right
if b1 is true b5 is true if B what is
false and b2 is true this is the
left-hand side so be three should be
true and again if these two things are
false left-hand side is G so before
better be true now that's kind of the
overall flavor of the system pi nite
solution space encoded using bullion's
translate the remaining constraints in
two clauses dump them off to the SAT
solver get the that tool to do all the
heavy lifting so an overview of this
whole system just to see how it all
connects together we take unannotated
code we put in these ghosts and all
these unknowns generate constraints pull
up these boolean variables encode the
constraints as a sap problem that then
we feed to chaff if we've been good and
you know the program is well typed or is
typo chaff will kind of chew on things
for a while eventually say yep this is
satisfiable here's a satisfying
assignment and we can take the
satisfying assignment that says be one
is false and stick it in right here
where we lost that piece but and it'll
say things like alpha 1 must be G and we
can stick those back into the source
program giving us a kind of explicitly
typed well type program so that's in the
good case in the bad case the chaff SAT
solver will say wait this problem is
unsatisfiable and then we know that the
program is is not well typed and in fact
what we do is we generate a separate SAP
problem for each different field
declaration in the program and so if
this side problem comes back as being
unsatisfiable we know there's a race
condition on this field and then we
variants of this that instead of
generating kind of this sat decision
problem actually generates a max at
optimization problem with the idea
saying even if you can't find protecting
locks for everything give me the best
guess at a lock that's used in most
places in the code
yeah so what is he away from exponential
intensity is sites magazine side of any
method in the program the worst case we
haven't really done a precise worst case
analysis all we know is its exponential
in the size of the program in practice
it scales quite well because i think the
subproblems we generate are very
straightforward and they can just be
so it is quite plausible that you'd be
able to do a better what worst-case
analysis we haven't really done that we
also only know that this type inference
problem is np-complete if you have if
you need at least three ghosts
parameters because kind of your three
sack Claus gets translated into three
different goals variables so if you only
need to ghost variables we don't
actually know that at MP complete so so
this works it's kind of disturbing that
you know there's potentially a
worst-case exponential algorithm sitting
in there but in practice we've run it on
a bunch of benchmarks kind of for pretty
small things up to jbb and these are
kind of semi standard benchmarks for
kind of the race condition literature
for java we did put in some annotations
by hand in these benchmarks for example
a say in this part of the program the
program is single threaded and so you
don't need to worry about
synchronization we also have a separate
analysis to reason about a threadlocal
and read only data which of course
doesn't need to be synchronized yep
annotation this part of the program is
single better how you say that you'd
need to ask Steve for all those details
he's been doing all the hands-on work I
think it's something like double slash
ampersand single threaded so the
beginning in yeah just some statement in
the program you say I'm single threaded
right here right and it's moderately
easy for a programmer to see that but
it's not something the tool can infer
but this is you know a few per thousand
lines of code so in terms of inference
time the tool isn't blazingly fast but
it's tolerable is typically about ten
seconds per thousand lines of code
notably worse on jbb but this still
terminates in
an hour so you know certainly usable and
more interesting is on all of these
benchmarks real to prove that upwards of
ninety percent of the fields are raised
free so it's kind of saying if you're
worried about race conditions you only
need to worry about some small fraction
of the fields in the Probie cuz
everything else we can kind of crank
through automatically okay so that's
yeah so the inference is done all these
on the whole program but what yes time
yes yes that you're just generating
audit logical formulas related to one of
you and then try to do something yes but
basically means that you cannot do this
analysis so one last time the sense that
you cannot get the most general
so for us yeah we have really developed
this as a whole program tool if you had
private fields you might be able to do
some kind of more modular analysis are
you can imagine putting in all of these
type annotations at your boundaries to a
class or a package and then just using
the tool to infer things within that say
class but in for example you have some
piece of code okay and you do this
analysis there now am i clear
perhaps it's dynamically daughter or
something right and that accesses a
field without holding a lot so that we
have violated right yes so so you can
you imagine that right it would be some
kind of compositional reasoning right
you can verify this is race free put
those obligations on your environment if
you dynamically coat load code that
violates that then all bets are off
yeah look at the fields which you could
not make sweet thanks for their
illnesses on some of these have real
races I don't remember off hand this was
almost too big to look at it's very hard
when you go into a you know a big cold
base try and figure out you say I don't
see any obvious synchronization on this
field but maybe there's something really
subtle going on that I just can't
understand but I think certainly many of
these are real races and I think there
are a real race in ray tracer as well
the paper on this has all of those
details yeah other people have find
similar races by and large yeah the
races are similar there is some some
differences
yep so when the silver ah provides you a
concrete
instance reyes how reasonable is that if
you have multiple instance that could
make a satisfiable you're just choosing
why right that this is because these
different sap problems for different
fields right so for your two different
fields will come back with two different
sets of annotations and we can kind of
just stitch those together basically if
to prove this field is correct we need
to say the class of parameter lies by
one thing and to prove this is correct
the plans of parameterize by another
thing then we say okay the class really
must have two parameters one that
protects its first field a different one
maybe the protected second so you have
as many parameters as a number of views
and every class conceivably yeah I mean
you will because you aren't gonna we're
gonna find those right um because you're
solving these problems separately then
how do you get it by the browser well if
the parameter isn't used in sub solution
say to prove that field I is and if
there's no races on field I if it
doesn't use a parameter yeah yeah yeah
no good
yeah so there is a whole step of
stitching those things together it's a
good point yep I don't know anything
about this other runtime race detection
tools that you can use which annotate
only the three incentive fields which
you couldn't be sure about here
and then simulate the program
does produce races
so yeah there's lots of dynamic race
detection tools and you could try and
focus those on these are conversely you
could try and use this kind of static
guarantee to optimize those other
dynamic raise detection tools and people
have looked and made a pretty good
progress on kind of a synthesis of
static and dynamic checking basically
using this kind well not this kind of
static analysis but static to optimize
the dynamic analysis yep a lot of the
complexity comes from the this ghost
right here what if you simply use
suppose you have a global naming
mechanism where you can distinguish
different logs for example by looking at
the type of the class and okay etc and
just use that common thing as a global
log if you will they don't need this
goes parameter right
so also how essential is it to introduce
to go
so in Java code I guess a lot of stuff
is really fine grained locking you
really do use an unbounded number of
locks and so some abstraction or
approximation that just has things in
terms of a finite set of locks the knob
and yeah if I just look at the type of
that class yes and use that as a unique
identifier for the log these efficient
so it would be unsound because you could
acquire the 1m and then access fields of
another which is kind of the difficulty
here that's that's why we need all of
this complexity it's kind of
domain-specific you do have some domains
for the embedded systems where typically
you just have a finite number of global
locks and then all this stuff goes away
things are a lot easier but in the Java
code we were looking at really that's
not the case most data structures are
very fine-grained locked there's lots of
little local locks around the place yep
in the annotated code that comes out of
the infra section haha how much bigger
is it than the original piece of code
like how many extra characters are you
adding to the furnace
I would guess roughly there is an
annotation on every field declaration
and every method declaration so that
would be pretty modest in terms of
percent overhead I'm guessing something
like ten percent yeah okay he said the
dullest difference for for unprivate
rised tap system is pretty
straightforward right also have you
tried this on this benchmark and seeing
how many views can be verified risk-free
on that one I'm worried about the
unnecessary from realization in the
sense that if you have just one bug or
some some whatever type in one function
you lose a lot of classes making an
extra presentation so the worry there is
that you get lots of false alarms and
all the good stuff will be so buried in
the false alarms that it would not have
much value we kind of did that by saying
let's parameterize it so we have no
ghost parameters / method and I can't
remember off hand but they were
significantly worse yep you're running
take run the three cents off or
sometimes you say yes but okay sometimes
it says no it doesn't verify but you've
mapped it into this three sad space yeah
how hard is it to unmap the you know you
get out usually you get a counterexample
at that point how useful over the
counter example is to actually say how
do i find this race my actual so the
first thing is the separate type problem
says the race is somewhere on field I
second is we have this max a problem
that says the races on field I and hey
the lock this protects most accesses to
I and doesn't protect the ones online 34
and 37 right and this is just a guess
yeah yeah accent well at least even
reverse translated these results pretty
it'll give you its best guess at a
protecting lock yeah so all of that is
on race conditions and i remember when i
was giving an early version of this talk
many years ago this guy I worked with
Andrew Burrell who did a lot of work
with multi-threaded codes ask me more or
less this question if we take something
this is a variant of the reference cell
so it has an increment class and it's
internally synchronized right so if this
is obvious stuff this kind of tell me to
speed up a little bit but basically the
idea is this method is has two
properties it's raised free and it
behaves correctly in a multi-threaded
context if you call ink from multiple
threads concurrently they all work just
fine and many programmers confuse these
two and think they're they're synonyms
write an address question is well what
about this method this is a different
way to write increment and this is
clearly raised free right every time you
access I you have the lock so you never
have concurrent accesses to I yeah so
the definition of a race condition is
two simultaneous accesses to a variable
by different threads yes ah
I'll get to it on the next slide but
right now you can you can intuitively
know that increment behaves badly if you
call it from multiple threads right it
kind of their the window of
vulnerability between these two critical
sections that if somebody else comes in
and says I'm going to increment I that
increment is going to be overwritten
right here it's going to be completely
ignored so I think intuitively we all
agree this is incorrect code it seems a
strange definition of rest rate I would
be inclined to redefine is free to say
right straight force against them except
then another sentient absolutely and so
there are different different
definitions of race free so I was
careful to give one particular
definition for this talk so in in that
notion of race freedom this is clearly
race free but erroneous and so kind of
the same question comes up what is the
right definition of race freedom or what
is the right definition of the behave
correctly in a multi-threaded
environment okay so so great freedom
does not prevent errors due to
unexpected interactions between threads
and so in some ways the right definition
of race freedom is what is often called
Adam icity and so a method informally is
atomic if other threads don't interfere
with its behavior more precisely it
really means kind of serializability
right so here we have some arbitrary
interleaved execution of this increment
method right so it requires a lock reads
I updates I and releases the lock and
there's another thread red thread doing
some arbitrary other things we don't
know quite what it is and there are lots
of different kinds of interleaved
executions right so Adam icity basically
means for every interleaved execution
there's a serial execution with the same
behavior where the instructions of the
increment method are all executed
contiguously without any interruption
yeah yep
it goes by different names as it's the
same as serializability our linearized
by looking a little bit different I
impotency is the statement of serial
execution observe from the outside
regardless of what may have happened on
the inside whereas atomicity is do it
always none of it so why I want to give
that so Adam icity in the database
literature has it has a different
meaning unfortunately what they would
call serializability the program
language literature calls atomicity and
isolation okay okay to the transition
okay so yes alpha rename atomicity as
need be and I'm sorry for the confusion
it's just kind of a collision of
terminology so if we can prove this it's
great right here there's all this
exponential combinatorial explosion
about different kinds of interleaving
here we just have to reason kind of
about the sequential behavior of
increment so if we can't prove Adam
icity our isolation reasoning about
program correctness gets a lot easier so
yeah also known by different terms in
different domains key benefit is that it
enables sequential reasoning so that's
all kind of old stuff what's interesting
here is it is a surprisingly good match
for the way people write existing code
particularly Java code is which is where
are all our experiments are in and
eighty or ninety percent of the code in
existing multi-threaded programs are
atomic and you know you look at the the
Javadoc specifications and really
programs are thinking of this way they
say this class is thread-safe roughly
translated as all of its methods or
atomic and the other interesting thing
is Adam icity like raise freedom is
fairly amenable to being a kind of
verified and a type system that you
could check at compile-time and the key
aspect of this type system are the key
reasoning that is doing is based on
Lipton's theory of reduction how
familiar are people with that theory of
reduction or should I review it okay so
it's a really nice argument it's
the key thing it leverages on is the
knowledge that the field I is raised
free so here we have some arbitrary
interleaved execution and if we know the
field I is raised free then we know that
whatever why does this thing of some
other thread it's not going to access
the field I because that would be a race
condition so these two operations they
commute doesn't really matter what order
these two instructions get done in and I
could say hey here's a different
execution their interleaved in a
different way but you have the same
final state right so that's the first
step now we acquire the lock so the blue
thread has a lock I don't know what the
red thread is doing but it cannot
acquire the lock of some other thread
hazard can't release the lock because it
doesn't have it so these operations
can't really mess with the lock at all
so those operations can commute does
that make sense and the same kind of
reason he applies here you know the blue
thread still has a lot so whatever Z
does it can't mess with the lock and
these operations commute and so by this
kind of commuting argument lipton was
able to show that for the increment
method provided there's no race
conditions and I increment is atomic
it's serializable using this commuting
argument so that's really neat how do we
do this in a type system so we already
have ways to reason about race freedom
so that's key and if we have a race free
variable access we can commute it either
way right in this case we choose kind of
to push this operation over to the right
but we could also push it over to the
left because X cannot be accessing I
either so race free operations commute
either way acquires we can always slide
to the right and releases we can kind of
slide to the left so we just need to
when we are type checker or compiler is
looking at the code for increment it
just needs to check our there's a bunch
of things that slide to the right and a
bunch of things that slide to the left
and if there's one operation in the
middle that doesn't slide at all that's
ok so the type checker goes over all of
the paths in the method and for each
operation along one of those pads it
assigns it one of these atomicity 'he's
either a right mover something like a
clock acquire left mover something like
a lock release at both mover if it's a
race free variable access and if it's a
conflicting variable access it says its
atomic it doesn't slide either way on
the slider on the kind of transparency
at all okay so if the type checker is
looking at this execution path acquire
read write and release it says it's a
right mover a both mover a both mover
and a left mover and then there's a
bunch of rules about how you combine
these different atomicity so if you have
a right mover in at both mover kind of
intuitively you can see that the whole
thing can move to the right so that is
still a right mover so right mover both
mover this is still one right mover we
add on another both mover this whole
thing is still a right mover and if we
have a right mover and a left mover the
whole thing is atomic so it looks at
this cold path it says a lot of
different kinds of movers I just put
them all together and I can infer that
the whole cool path is atomic and it
just does that over all of the code
paths or more properly over all of the
kind of the things in the abstract
syntax tree okay so if we look at the
bad version of increment
this is an alpha renamed version of
increment that's no called deposit but
acquire read release acquire right
release it's a right mover both mover
left mover this whole thing is atomic
we've the same critical section over
here is also atomic but if you try and
compose to atomic sections together we
get this atomicity compound saying wait
there's no guarantee I mean other
threads could interrupt here and do
strange things and particularly that's
exactly true other threads can come in
here and kind of override balance okay
that making sense so we have you've seen
some of these data messages but they're
not always quite enough so here we have
a deposit method as much as we've seen
and we have this method deposit twice
that calls deposit twice and let me
throw out this question to you so we've
already seen this kind of method and we
know it's atomic how about this method
is it atomic
yeah indeed it is but if we try and feed
us through the type checker what the
type checker will think is well of
course deposited is atomic deposit twice
has various things including a call to
deposit this atomic another call to the
positive atomic if we sequentially
compose these two things together we get
compound and so the type checker will
complain about this method so that's
kind of not good right we have some
correctness argument that the positronic
but the type checker cannot prove it so
we need to beef up the type checker a
little bit to be able to reason about
this and the key thing that's going on
is we need a more precise spec for
deposit it's not enough to say it's
atomic I mean certainly it's always
atomic but what if it's called when the
lock is held exactly the situation here
so if the lock is already held Java has
reentrant lock so this lock acquire it's
really a no op right so instead of this
pattern so then we have a whole bunch of
movers altogether it's just the same as
mover so what we're seeing is if the
lock this is held deposit is a mover
otherwise it's atomic that's exactly the
kind of spec that we need to put down so
we add those kinds of specifications to
our atomicity type system basically
saying is the lock this is held the
methods a mover otherwise it's atomic we
go down here and that's the spec for
deposit but in this context the lock is
indeed held right
so we do a bit of reasoning we say ah we
have a lock acquire right mover a both
move are both mover a left mover the
whole thing is atomic and and the type
checker is happy you can verify
atomicity yeah you will have this
language of conditional atomicity to be
and still be able to check okay so these
could be arbitrary things so you can
have kind of complicated nested decision
trees it can arbitrary atomicity and the
lock expressions can be any java
expression with the requirement that it
must be const must always evaluate is
the same thing and cannot touch any
mutable data right if you can only touch
final variables and final fields and
then there's a caveat that final fields
aren't quite final kinds of
initialization but a punt on that a
little bit okay so if we apply this to
things we applied it to a whole bunch of
kind of standard Java libraries that are
supposed to be thread-safe and found a
bunch of interesting things and this is
kind of illustrative of it right so the
increment method with the soup
synchronized blocks right that's a very
artificial example well you kind of
throw in one level of indirection
through a method call and you get lots
of examples like this so here we have a
constructor for a vector that just takes
in some collection c and supposed to
initialize the vector with the contents
of that collection so it calls c.length
to get the length of the vector which is
an atomic method it then allocates some
space to store that data and then it
calls si dottore to copy and all of that
stuff and the type checker said well
this is atomic sure allocation is a both
mover doesn't mess with other threads
but to the to array is also atomic so it
said this whole method is compound and
complained let me go went in and looked
at this and we said well you know this
is absolutely right we could call count
to get the length of C then some other
three I could say hey I am going to make
see bigger I'll add to that collection
we come down here when we call si
dottore except
because he has gotten bigger data is too
small so what does to already do in that
situation it says ah the array you gave
me was too small i'm going to allocate a
new array the copy my stuff into i'm
going to return that new array to you
and that return array is dropped on the
floor meaning that data is still 0
initialized and you get kind of some
weird behavior down the road when you
certainly have this vector that was
never initialized with the collection it
was supposed to be initialized with so
we get kind of lots of corner case
errors like this that will be very hard
to catch using testing so I am a little
bit at a time so let me try and wrap up
very briefly so of course the same issue
comes up you have a whole bunch of
legacy code you have a nice type system
to reason about it Adam icity but it's a
pain to write the annotations you really
want type inference the type inference
turns out to be a much easier problem we
kind of have a constraint-based type
inference algorithm no exponential time
no sad stuff or anything like that
kind of at each method we have this
lattice of possible specs for the method
Const means boy I always return the same
thing mover says I don't interfere with
other threads we've left and right
movers we have conditional atomicity
that we've seen that we need some
methods are atomic all the methods are
compound they interfere with other
threads and even beyond that we've
methods that are error that say I
violate the locking discipline and it's
bad if you get any of those we have a
whole constraint-based type inference
algorithm and the performance of this
algorithm in comparison to the race free
type system is quite fast so it's you
know maybe a second or two per a
thousand lines of code jbb let me see
yeah so basically even for large
programs up to thirty thousand lines of
code it's about seconds more
interestingly is how precise it is so
within these various benchmarks for most
of them it was quite nice we were able
to prove that about upwards of eighty
percent of these methods are atomic
which means that you know for
four-fifths of your code sequential
reasoning is just fine right there's
this little gap at the top where
multi-threading really comes into play
and you need to do more complicated
things but most of the time you know
you're still living in a sequential
world and we're kind of able to isolate
that sequential world within
multi-threaded software TSP is
noticeably worse and what's going on
there is kind of this I think what's
called a branch and bound algorithm you
have a bunch of threads looking to solve
an optimization problem and there's a
global variable that says this is the
best solution I found so far and
everybody's kind of racing on that
variable but they're benign races but
you do need to worry about all these
interactions of threads we also looked
at a bunch of classes that were
documented is thread-safe and again
similar kinds of things upwards of
eighty percent of these methods we could
verify as thread safe here the
interesting thing was with a print
writer which is kind of a wrapper around
Oh stream what these warnings were
complaining about it is essentially
saying what he had someone I old stream
that you pass to this constructor for
print wrapper and I know print wrapper
always holds a lock when it rights to
that iostream but I'm worried somebody
else might keep an old handle to the
underlying iostream and write to that
without the lock and so that's really
what these warnings are about and it's
kind of a valid concern right so you
know you call println on a print writer
and it prints the string but then
there's another thread that does
something to the underlying stream and
insert some characters and then you get
the new line right so println really
wouldn't be atomic in that situation
okay and then the last part so what
we've seen is a type system that you'll
give code like this it'll infer some
atomicity annotations and here the user
specified on the original program this
should be atomic and the type system
will say wait no that's not the case but
of course as soon as you get an error
like this you say boy well I guess I
need to figure out what the right lock
is I need to go in and insert all that
lock insert the synchronization code so
we've also been playing with
synchronization correction the idea is
saying you don't really I guess when you
get this error message you want a quick
fix button that says does this
automatically for you it kind of looks
at your code and says wait your
synchronization wasn't quite right here
and put in extra synchronized clauses as
necessary so that kind of constraint
based inference algorithm to infer
atomicity we've extended to also infer
when things go wrong what
synchronization could have been put in
there that would make things okay
yeah Adam the city does your atomicity
inference system in for conditional
animus and yes yeah
yeah there's a whole bunch of details
that I kind of ran out of time on yeah
it looks so here's the thing it'll
introduce enough synchronization so that
this method is atomic you probably want
to worry about deadlocks too and that's
just kind of an orthogonal issue that we
don't really deal with maybe you want to
eyeball it and say yeah that looks right
maybe you want to use some other
deadlock detection tool of the entire
program is something main nervous that
is true so the deadlock is certainly an
issue so we didn't deal with that there
are other tools to do it's in our view
and orthogonal issue but important what
we did do is we took a bunch of classes
standard Java library classes and we
said well suppose we inserted a couple
of bugs in there basically saying going
in removing synchronization how well
will our tool will do it automatically
kind of fixing those bugs and so by and
large and here if we just insert one bug
you know we do a whole bunch of samples
we say how about if you remove this one
how about if you remove this how about
if we remove this if we just insert one
bug by and large it works pretty well
two bugs is a little bit worse than five
bug that's still doing okay string is
mostly an immutable class it doesn't
have many synchronized statements in
there it doesn't even have five of them
so we couldn't run that experiment so
this is showing that this works
reasonably well as long as you're you
don't have too much too many
synchronization errors if you've lots of
synchronization errors the the max a
problem cannot even conjecture a good
protecting lock for your fields and
that's kind of where things go wrong
it's kind of starting to happen in
places like this okay so I'm at the end
of my are so that is about it so type
inference from right conditions with
these ghost parameters turns out to be
np-complete but by leveraging advances
in SAT solvers this seems to work pretty
well up to as far as we've pushed it
about thirty thousand lines of code and
can verify over ninety percent of fields
as race free we've also extended this
type based approach to animosity
on moderately big benchmarks like jbb we
can prove that eighty percent of methods
are atomic and some progress on
synchronization correction kind of more
on a class local basis for thread-safe
classes yeah its analysis and you can
find out in these programs that you know
most of the program is atomic anyway did
I see the need for software
transactional memory so I hate software
transactional memory and I love it the
reason I hate it is it makes all of this
work redundant right you put a topic in
there and while you're done yeah I
philosophy is I can see reasons to
reason about threads and locks
explicitly low-level stuff right you
don't want the overhead of transactions
if you do have transactions threads and
transactions seem to me to be a funny
thing right it's kind of high level in
terms of transactions but you know I
don't like threads anyway maybe one kind
of thread level speculation or something
like that something that preserves a
more sequential model of programming
maybe if you've a domain that amenable
to MapReduce that the great model to
program in transactions to me seemed a
little bit like C++ trying to span a
huge abstraction boundary from
high-level objects down to low-level
bits right transactions are high-level
thread seem kind of low-level for many
applications and of course there's this
issue sometimes you have threads because
your application is naturally thread at
a web server and sometimes you have to
force threads in just to get all the
cores to run and the second kind of
threading is is the thing that you know
in an ideal world would go away so
that's a bunch of rambling thoughts and
answer your question okay thanks
assuming that this kind of cool group
employed widely and people write a lot
of code now Java and C sharp yeah you
know the sort of the claim is it race
conditions and getting multi-threaded
programming right is hard and you know
and you spend a lot of these for later
Fox do you believe that would be true
you have the tools in place I think I
guess we've got all the low-hanging
fruit right we can prove eighty percent
of the methods of atomic that's fine and
the remaining twenty percent is you know
it's still going to be hard and you need
some other approach to tackle that and
i'm testing won't quite do it and you
could try code inspection and that would
probably be pretty good but very
time-intensive difference is that now
people don't know that it is eighty
percent absolutely not yeah so so that
gives you factor five right there yes
not an effort that you would put in yes
so that seems pretty substantial I mean
you know in terms of terms of leverage
on solving this problem so it certainly
gives you a lot of leverage the stuff
you kind of felt was okay now you know
is okay and the stuff you were always
worried about well you're still worried
about it so yeah it gives you a lot of
advantage I don't know if I mean it
makes a problem smaller but it doesn't
go away so yeah I'm maybe we should chat
offline about transactional memory too
yeah boss a free program in it but if it
is atomic clock program we will say
orgia lamport's bakery algorithm we will
say we cannot verify this method is
atomic and you can go in and you can do
things like the clearer method is a time
i can put an O morn on it and then the
underlying the type system will just
assume it's atomic but you better be
sure you're right because you know
everything relies on that yep
question so if you had these static race
detection tools are available right a
half would do you think there'd be
really much need for the dynamic race
detection tools yes again for that last
ten percent but it would get rid of a
lot of a lot of the phones that we
currently have yes yeah yep you need to
ask some additions for a threadlocal yes
some of them I imagine would involve a
call stack that uses the synchronized
key word right yes some might be the
case where in the path you don't to use
synchronization at all but yet it should
be under body started the environment so
if you have an assessment life you know
what's the percentage of those cases
the I think my real question is that if
I just follow the the past and to see
whether it uses implementation at all
and use that as the heuristic just today
whether it's single-stranded or money
started without this occasion ah so the
thing go threaded versus multi-threaded
I'm sure there are so we haven't really
tackled that problem we just put in an
assertion that it was and leverage it
and I'm sure you could come up with
different kinds of static analyses to do
that it's just we haven't done that yeah
the type inference for race race freedom
yes the results you recorded for how
many few you are able to verify race
free okay well with respect to a certain
number of annotation yes if you started
out saying all animations
yes I was not much hbu the announcer
they will be worse I'm probably a factor
of two then you will do our virus with a
portion of the few i don't remember
offhand that part of work was done in
about a year ago but it that could be
ballpark
yeah but you know the number of
annotations there to me doesn't doesn't
seem to be excessive me if you actually
said that okay you actually have to do
so via annotations that you would have
done in the previous type system or
without any inference I'm not finding
what is the cost of annotations relative
cost of annotation I mean you are lying
on it right might as well say that just
yet the whole damn thing and dual I
think it brings down the overhead by
about a factor of 10 it's about one
annotation per thousand lines of code
versus maybe one annotation for ten or
tens of lines of code probably more like
one every 10 so yeah this is a lot of
leverage their for the race freedom type
system education burden for the
atomicity types why that's a good one um
both with the versions of inference
Steve would have all the details on that
because he was the one I had to go
through and you know put them in by hand
I am guessing that in some ways a race
freedom is the harder thing and they
would be somewhat more uh would run the
race freedom type infant before you on
the anniversary yes yes yeah that's not
the way it all work yeah yeah and i
think the i don't think there were many
are extra ones needed for the atomicity
type system at all it was all at the
first step to verify race freedom you
need to look in your examples you had
marked methods to speak
yes ah so that very good point i was a
bit remission skipping this
so what we're doing here is we are
basically going in and not by hand but
inside the tools saying try and prove
every methods atomic and if not give us
a warning because we didn't really write
the code we don't know which one should
be atomic so of this gap here maybe
there are some methods that should be
atomic and there is an error in the code
maybe it is atomic and we cannot verify
it or maybe it's a method that the
program never intended to be atomic like
that main right and we were just foolish
to try and prove it was atomic anyway
and I'm not exactly sure how this gap
divides into those three categories here
we're a lot more confident that really
all of these methods were intended to be
atomic because they were documented as
being threadsafe and so this is likely
either errors or approximations in the
analysis and some of them are indeed
errors so there there's no annotations
no other than this kind of annotation on
the side this heuristic that says
everything should be atomic
yep how incremental in this approach
after you infer some annotations and
then programmers coming to say that but
this is too complicated at a set of
validations that were corrected this way
and then the later will do you first
again to detect with the complicated
yeah it's a as implemented it's a whole
program analysis and if you change the
code while you do the analysis from
scratch you Joe already improved yeah
and you could imagine kind of
restructuring this to be an incremental
analysis and that's kind of a a step
down the road I guess our first thought
was to say let's implement it and see if
if it actually works and later on try
and make it fast there are ya
and in fact we use them in part because
we have a bunch of very similar staff
problems the first one trying to prove
field is raised free and then we prove
field j is raised for you and we've
experimented with using the incremental
versions of SAT solvers with some
benefit there
okay oh thanks for your attention